I thought we'd talk about chat GPT no
one's been talking about that right it's
not been mentioned I think it is both
equal parts valuable and overhyped and
that's the best kind of AI right I'm not
going to talk about how it's trained
today well I've done a great video on
how it's trained you've done a video
before on gpt3 which is broadly based
off and oh that's bad no no no no no oh
oh that's really bad Philip Moriarty has
also done a video on the 60 symbols
Channel about if it's possible to cheat
with chat GPT and so I suppose what I'm
interested in talking about is is it
possible to detect cheaters in chat GPT
and how easy is that to do
I've been looking at this really
interesting paper by uh John
kirchenbauer and colleagues at the
University of Maryland on if you were
trying to change the output of a large
language model like chat GPT or any of
the others in some subtle way that
allowed it to be detected
as AI generated rather than human
generated how might that look right and
I think that's a really interesting
question not does this system exist can
it exist I just think if it was to exist
what would be a good way of Designing it
right I suppose you might think that the
most obvious way would be would just try
another neural network right that's what
we always do
so why don't we train a large language
model to detect the output of large
language models and the answer is
firstly that's very inefficient
um difficult to do but also someone will
release a slightly different trained
large language model although refine
refine the language model to some other
slightly different task or even the same
task again train it for a bit longer the
output will be subtly different and then
it won't work right and another problem
is that for some tasks there is only one
answer so if I say to an AI write me a
piece of code to iterate over a list it
may do that and a student would probably
give me the exact same answer in which
case labeling that student's answer as a
I like would be incorrect right so it's
not obvious how you would solve this
problem by just training another Network
so this paper comes at it in an entirely
different way what we want to try and do
is subtly change the output to avoid
certain words and by doing so we can
detect that that's happened with a
higher probability right so we can say
there is very little chance that the
lack of words is based on chance alone
this was generated using an AI and then
there's other questions you've got to
ask like how do you do this in a way
that doesn't make it so that the text is
unreadable and or not very good right so
that's what this paper is about and
that's why it's really really
interesting why don't we first recap
very very briefly how a large language
model that's trained on next word
prediction which is to say quite a lot
of them uh that's what it does right and
the answer is will you give it a prompt
right so you you can give it your prompt
yourself if you actually go on the
website but there were also prompts that
happen automatically as part of apis or
and there's also extra prompt that goes
in before you even start typing right to
try and tell it who it is for example
right you're you're a um a large
language model trained by open AI I
think is the the text but I keep seeing
over and over again and I'm getting a
bit bored of so a large language model
takes some text so this is going to be T
T1 T2 TT three two four that's your
prompt and then we want to know what is
the next token in the sentence we can
then iterate this process so we can say
to the large language model what's the
next word in the sentence it will do it
and then we can say okay now given T
naught I didn't write a naught there you
go given T naught one two three four and
now T5 you just gave me what's T6 and we
can repeat this process to generate very
long streams of of text right and this
works really nicely as as we've seen
right is there any way we can kind of
inject ourselves into this process to
influence what it does well the way that
this generates text is it doesn't
actually tell you what the next word is
it essentially tells you how likely it
is right so you might have a sentence
that says something like I
man up
the right and then for every word it
could produce it tells you how likely it
is to come next right so a few examples
right Hill
right a slope I guess
stairs stairs yep
and then it perhaps are slightly out
there football right which doesn't make
any sense as a sentence right so this
the likelihood of Hill I would say is
fairly fairly likely so that would have
a high likelihood slope may be a
slightly less likelihood they should be
the same width uh stairs maybe a bit
less and football was just a teeny
likelihood because no one's written that
sentence ever because it's stupid right
the procedure for using language model
would then generate one of these words
based on their likelihoods right now
there's different strategies you could
do for doing this but you could imagine
picking them with a chance that's
related to How likely they are right so
you're this likely to choose Hill and a
little bit less likely to slope and
almost impossible that you choose
football and then the variations on this
theme how could we change the network to
show that it was generated by an AI well
the first thing we could do is we could
just start injecting words like football
where they don't belong right and so we
could say well why am I up the football
and everyone go it was definitely
generated by AI it's also not usable in
any sense right so we don't want to do
that what we're going to do is we're
going to generate a red list of words
that we mustn't use at any given time
time step so we take the previous word
in a sentence that was generated the and
we use that to seed a random number
generator which splits all of the words
into red or green right so let's say
Hill is red
slope is green I could actually use red
and green for this can you imagine it's
never going to catch on right so this is
Red Hill is red always this is this is
going to work
um slope is
I've just worn a green circle around
as well all right you're gonna leave
that in the edit aren't you all right
Hills green right and we'll say no about
it slope is red stairs is red and
football is green right it's a terrible
example because Hill's already the most
likely there could be many hums of words
we could use in that sentence right and
discounting them completely so this is
four examples I thought up this is a
very long list of possible words and
what we're going to do is we're going to
reduce the chance that we pick slope and
stairs right or indeed increase the
chance that we're going to pick these
green words right and what that would is
it makes football slightly more likely
but luckily we also made Hills slightly
more likely and then the process is
unchanged all we've done is dissuade it
from using the red words and promote the
idea of using these green words and then
we've chosen a random word like before
so maybe we choose Hill so we're going
to write Hill in so then we're going to
do the next token in the sentence so we
put in hill we calculate a hash and we
see our random number generate and that
re-partitions our vocabulary into a new
set of red and green right and I was
going to write and after this so I ran
up the hill and then something happened
but and has now unfortunately been put
on the Red List Right sort of chance of
picking and has been reduced maybe then
has been lifted up so maybe then is a
green word and so on right so we're
going to subtly influence which words
get picked now if you do this then when
you're verifying this later you can come
back and say well given that we were the
what was the red list ingredients we can
recompute it by seeding the same random
number generator we can calculate the
hill screen given now that Hill is the
next word we can see that Ben is green
but then we can see that we produce and
then we is a red word and then went
maybe is a green word and we can count
the number of red and green words that
we achieved now given that we're
randomly splitting our data set into two
there's roughly a 50 chance for any
given word is going to be partitioned
into red or green but if we're
dissuading the network subtly from
producing red words there's going to be
a lot more greens in here than there are
red right and so over a paragraph of
text or even a few a sentence or two of
text if you've got mostly green that is
extremely strong evidence that you were
running through an AI that had this
running on it right where we subtly
influence the output so I'm now I think
you already store things like kind of
that random number seed or how do you
get to that so
what we wouldn't want to do is split the
data set once and for all into red and
green and then stick with it right
because then you would have a really
important word like football does get
used in sentences as red and we'd be
dissuaded from using it and then you
couldn't ask your AI about football at
all right which I don't but you know you
could this is why this seeding of the of
the random function makes so much sense
because it produces a new red green list
every time you move to the next word in
a sentence and so this is just stored
transitly very quickly right it doesn't
take long to Hash this it doesn't take
long to see the random number generator
and it doesn't take long to determine
whether a word is in the red or green
list so this adds a negligible amount of
run time to your already pretty
significant computational resource of
running the language model at all
but when we come to actually analyze the
results we can look at this for each one
we can say okay what was the red and
green list at that time is this red or
green what was the red and green list at
the time is this red or green and we can
count up the number of Reds and greens
and then we can perform a statistical
test that says if this was a real
sentence that where it was 50 each red
and green but we've actually got this
amount what are the chances that this
was by chance right and the Chance is
vanishingly low even for short sentences
so it's not quite as simple as this
right which is why there's about 25
pages in this paper and not one the
problem we have is sometimes the the
next word is incredibly obvious right so
the example from the paper is when the
first word is Barack right very likely
the second word is going to be Obama you
happen to pick a red word at that time
Obama was classified as red you might
not use it and then you've got Barrack
something else and it and it's just not
going to read well as a sentence right
so the key is you dissuade it from using
these things but you don't completely
discount them you don't this is not like
where you're restricted from using any
word on a red list you're just subtly
reduced so that means a situation where
you had word a word b and word c all of
which had equal likelihood then what
will happen is this word is on the red
list this word will probably not get
picked because this will come down and
these two will stay high if you had a
situation like here where Hill is
already pretty likely even if it got red
listed it will probably still pick Hill
and what they call this is is sort of a
high and low entropy sentences so a
sentence is where the next word is so
obvious that you can't really safely
change it without it being really really
ruining the output and so you don't
right you just dissuade it from using
um the red words but it has no effect if
it's overwhelmingly likely to pick a
specific word but in a situation where
choosing between then and didn't really
make any difference in the quality of a
centers we produced then yes you can
dissuade it and that makes a subtle
difference on the number of green and
reds that we see in the output now the
paper goes into a lot more detail for
example it's possible to seed our
pseudo-random number generation off the
previous few words instead of one
um and there were various attacks you
could launch on this so it was an
interesting one on Twitter where someone
had
um chat GPT produce an essay where it
put Emojis between every word now that
means that the Emojis are going to
generate the same hash which could
generate the exact same green and red
distinctions in which case you've got
yourself a problem because you can
delete them and and then you've got
random assignments right so there's lots
of interesting attacks on this but in
principle I think it could work right
which I think is quite interesting right
now
you know the implementation issues
you've got to convince people like open
AI who run these models to implement a
system like this you've got to convince
everyone else to do it right because if
there's an equally good language model
that doesn't do this people will use
this right but if a situation we're in
at the moment is but there are only a
few language models that are really
capable of doing what gbt3 and chat GPT
can do and so in which case if those
companies got on board you might have a
system like this where it would allow
you to make use of these methods which
are really useful for having dialogue
and chatting with and learning things
without actually passing off their
output as your homework right which
really at that point you're not learning
anything necessarily at all right in the
long term I think what we'll probably
end up doing is not worrying quite so
much about whether an essay is generated
this way we'll be asking different
things of students maybe working with
the AI or whatever the AI looks like in
five months time depending on how fast
it's going right and you know you might
see it's a more collaborate
collaborative thing and it's just a tool
that we use but at the moment we're in
that kind of slightly odd position
between it's become a tool that we use
and we know how to use it and it's
messing around with all our exams right
and that's so that's the that's the
place we're in could you suppose you
wanted to cheat could you generate an
essay but had that had a system like
this and then change sufficient words
the answer is that you would need to
change a lot of words because you've got
to go from almost no red words to about
50 red words and you might as well write
it well yeah at that point it is it is
starting to become easier just to learn
the material and write the essay right
um so you know you have to make that
choice
oh that's really bad the very first line
is nonsense
anytime you can get more likely to get
approval by deceiving the person you're
talking to that's better
um and this is a thing that actually did
happen